on this wall in Almaty in Kazakhstan are
the faces of people who were held in
China relatives say they're being held
in internment camps with Beijing calls
reeducation camps to counter what it
calls extremism goal Xia was held in
such a camp she didn't talk about her
experience until after she'd been
awarded citizenship in Kazakhstan
she says abuse she suffered has scarred
her for life and she frequently suffers
headaches when I was crossing the border
they saw I am using whatsapp I was
detained and sent for a thorough medical
test they found I am pregnant and forced
me to abort after the abortion they
isolated me in a clinic they gave me
some medicine which they said was for
tuberculosis I don't know what it was
members of the Turkic community accused
Chinese authorities of using abortions
as a weapon against Muslims either women
afraid to reveal their identities have
also told Al Jazeera about abuse at the
camps
the relative safe haven in Kazakhstan is
only for its nationals and does not
apply to ethnic Kazakhs who are Chinese
nationals and that's among the causes
creating anti-china sentiment inside
kazakhstan dozens of people were
arrested in neutral town in Almaty
during an anti signer demonstration in
September
these men crossed illegally into
Kazakhstan after they reportedly faced
harassment by Chinese authorities cast
iron Musa Han and Mirage air ally Molly
now risk being sent back to China
activists say events like this fuel anti
signer sentiment and Kazakhstan should
not roll over for its powerful neighbor
if Jews prosecuted in massively are
persecuted for example in Russia in
Europe Israel states they will talk
against of its Kazakh governments must
defend any ethnic Kazakh in the world
this analysts working with a government
funded think tank says the China
Kazakhstan relationship is a delicate
subject Jewish is a domestic Chinese
internal affairs but the same time if
you take take into account the United
Nations motions on the we go if you're
collec stance of position was quite
pragmatic and we abstained from voting
on this motion so we have more
independent stance and about the same
time we realize that your political
reality so I believe it's a Kazakh style
diplomacy where we try to sustain the
relation at the same time show our case
some questions why should Kazakhstan
oppose China with which it shares a 1700
kilometer border when other
muslim-majority countries support
Beijing earlier this year more than a
dozen member countries of the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation or
oh I see signed a statement in favor of
China's policies commenting on
internment camps the Chinese Foreign
Ministry spokeswoman has said the Rieger
ethnicity is part of the big family
consisting of 56 ethnic groups in China
tightly united together like the seeds
of a pomegranate they're living a better
life and fully enjoy freedom and rights
China also enjoys friendly and close
relations with the vast majority of
Muslim countries in the world many
ethnic Kazakhs say China is violating
human rights on a large scale in the
name of fighting terrorism they say
their next generation is being killed
before birth and their Muslim identity
is being systematically erased yet they
argue there is no leader from the
Islamic world standing up to support
them sama bin Javed al Jazeera Almaty
Kazakhstan